côté campagne toujours vous avez mené
une campagne électorale en fait assez
agressive envers Jean Germain avec des
mots parfois très durs est-ce que on est
obligé d'en arriver là certains
d'ailleurs ont décrit cette tactique de
campagne finalement comme le signe d'une
faiblesse
j'ai dit par exemple que son projet de
tramway était mal étudié je vous le
redis ce soir
dans le vide
son projet est mal étudié je suis contre
son projet et ça je le dis sans
agressivité parce qu'il faut que les
tours en jeu sachent avec moi ce à quoi
ils peuvent s'attendre maintenant les
petites phrases ça m'intéresse pas j'ai
un projet très positif mais quand on
m'attaque je réponds voilà quand il
parle par exemple à mon propos de
paillettes c'est absolument ridicule
vouloir faire venir un certain nombre de
gens dans notre ville des investisseurs
des entreprises des talents il y en a
déjà beaucoup qui existent mais vouloir
en assurer le rayonnement voilà quand on
me caricature je réponds